as the movie begins we see a nervous
looking man entering a large Temple to
worship it is a dark and mysterious
place which looks like it's been
deserted for some time however there are
drum beats coming from somewhere despite
no one being around Jumanji as the man
looks around in confusion a Titanic God
suddenly awakens revealing that the
drumbeat was in fact his heartbeat he is
now awoken to unleash hell on Humanity
following this we are shown a man named
Guan who is frantically searching for
his daughter Tangerine inside of an
ancient Mystic cave the little girl
appears to be screaming from the depths
of the cave all of a sudden a glowing
deity materializes in front of Guan
stopping him from moving any further he
jolts awake and realizes it was actually
a dream not another cave daughter deity
dream this is when we find out that
guan's daughter Tangerine was kidnapped
six years ago and has been missing ever
since as a sorrowful father he has been
obsessed with finding his daughter at
any cost this Obsession has led him to
sell his house abandon his career and
even divorce his wife sitting alone on
the side of a cliff Guan notices a truck
on the road and begins throwing rocks at
it with pinpoint accuracy even changing
the trajectory along the way the rocks
break the truck's windshield causing the
vehicle to crash nearby Guan makes his
way down the cliff and attacks the
driver demanding to know where his
daughter is suddenly the driver's
accomplice hits Guan in the head with a
wrench knocking him down while they
escape on foot shortly after Guan gets
up and checks the truck where he finds
many children locked up and kept in
cages it is then revealed that he
somehow found out about the traffickers
and ambushed their vehicle in hopes of
saving his daughter however
disappointment hits Guan when he doesn't
find his daughter inside soon the cops
arrive and arrest Guan assuming that he
is the trafficker he falls asleep in the
back of the cop car and dreams of
Tangerine again but this time he sees
her entangled in Black slimy Vines Oh I
thought this movie was set in China not
Japan upon waking up a while later he
notices the cop has taken the picture of
his daughter out of his pockets this
enrages Guan so much that he breaks free
and forcefully snatches the picture
before escaping strangely enough he
finds another car on the road waiting
for him due to the dire circumstances
Guan doesn't think twice and gets inside
the car the driver is a lady named Ling
who happens to know everything about
gwan's life including his daughter's
disappearance she then convinces him to
stay claiming that she can help him find
his daughter the movie Cuts back to the
ancient setting where we see a warrior
named Kong running away from attackers
led by an old man Kong eventually finds
himself surrounded on the edge of a
cliff but just as the tension reaches
its peak his sister comes to the rescue
she defends Kong and instructs him to go
west before pushing him off the cliff
for his own safety after that we see her
fight off the remaining goons all on her
own scared for his sister's life Khan
climbs back up the cliff only to find
that she has been killed by the old man
the latter is also impaled through the
chest and so Kong takes the spear out
intending to kill him the old man warns
Kong that if he kills him he will never
be able to run from someone named Lord
redmaine nevertheless Kong kills the old
man and avenges his sister after the
chaos finally ends Kong is heartbroken
and tired of always running from his
enemies hence he decides to return to
the city and kill his biggest enemy Lord
Redmayne all of a sudden the Old Man's
armor starts moving it is in need of a
new host and so it instantly attaches
itself to Kong as it turns out the armor
has its own will and it wants to be a
part of Kong's mission to kill Lord
Redmayne it fully embeds itself in his
body and an eyeball appears on Kong's
chest as an indication meanwhile Ling
takes Guan into the building where she
works and proceeds to show him pictures
of five girl toddlers she asks him if he
recognizes his daughter but
unfortunately Guan is unable to do so as
it has been a very long time since he
last saw her Ling then states that they
can use a DNA test to find out which one
is daughter but in exchange Guan has to
be of service to her company Ling
reveals that they know about his power
to control projectiles and want to see
him use it to kill a novel writer named
Kong she then shows and explains Kong's
daily live streams in which he narrates
stories written by himself The Peculiar
thing is that whenever one of the
novel's characters named Lord Redmayne
gets wounded in the story Ling's company
Boss Lee moo gets hurt in real life the
company has tried every possible legal
strategy to make Kong stop writing the
story but to no avail Guan finds the
story hard to believe but he has no
choice but to accept the offers it is
his only way of locating his daughter
Tangerine so the next day Juan gets
himself a fresh new haircut helya Guan
and travels to the small town where Kong
Lives on his way there he discovers that
the things he frequently dreams about
are related to Kong's stories as he
listens to them on his audiobook Guan
follows Kong all day waiting for the
opportune moment to kill him and
eventually ends up inside a library
however he fails to blend in as there is
no one else in the library besides Kong
and him that didn't stop Keanu Reeves
from killing a basketball player in John
Wick 3. suddenly the writer confronts
Guan and asks why he has been following
him all day to which the latter responds
by pretending to be a fan of his novels
hearing this Kong becomes ecstatic and
asks Guan a lot of questions but before
our protagonist can answer them he gets
a call from Lang prompting him to move
to the side and to pick it up she orders
him not to talk with the Target and
execute him immediately however Guan
doesn't listen to her and continues to
follow Kong outside the two engage in a
conversation again and are almost hit by
a car from Link's company Guan flees the
scene but he accidentally leaves his
dream journal behind when Kong goes
through it he is immediately struck with
inspiration for a new plot in his most
recent book the movie then Cuts back to
the fictional world where Kong travels
to the city where people are celebrating
a festival the venue for the ceremony
has a massive statue of Lord Redmayne
revealing that he is the one being
celebrated Kong is baffled at the number
of people when suddenly the statue
points its arm towards the neighboring
Village and they all run towards it with
their weapons the alive armor explains
to a confused Kong that Lord redmaine is
responsible for the destruction of many
villages as he has been manipulating all
of his followers to start a war the
neighboring Villages also arm themselves
for defense but their attempt is futile
as three huge fire dragons appear from
the sky and dump flammable liquid all
over their base afterward the ground
troops sent fire arrows towards the
village resulting in the entire base
Going Up in Flames making them lose the
war a while later the village is seen to
be in Ruins and as the sun rises a
battle horn is heard prompting several
nights in Crimson rad to arrive on
horses Kong also notices the flag and
deduces that the Knights of Red Man's
disciples the remaining villagers cower
in fear while the knights set up a
curfew in order the movie Cuts back to
the real world where Guan wakes up
inside a hotel room and finds a ling
sitting beside him she punishes him for
his absence of Mind as he didn't do what
he was supposed to shortly after Kong
arrives outside the hotel and hands Guan
the journal back he also thanks him for
the inspiration he needed to continue
his novel in the next scene Guan takes
Kong for a walk intending to lure him to
a secure place so that he can get the
job done they make their way to an
abandoned field while Kong talks about
how he got into storytelling and writing
it's then revealed that he had started
writing exactly six years ago strangely
being the same time when Guan had lost
his daughter Tangerine Kong then hears a
sweet melody in the distance and jots
down some notes so that he can add to
the story in the fictional World Kong
finds a little girl on the streets
trying to revive her dead brother she is
revealed to be none other than Tangerine
feeling pity he consoles her and then
buries the boy as the two start chatting
Tangerine reveals that the Crimson
Knights will try to kill anyone who
leaves their home after Sunset then she
starts to play the flute which
replicates the same tune the novel
writer Kong had heard in the real world
this sound attracts the attention of a
knight who hunts them down as it is
already Sunset Khan eventually decides
to swap the girl with a decoy to give
her a chance to escape while he stalls
the Knight after a while the Knight
finally catches up to him and falls for
the decoy as he has left stunned Kong
takes advantage of the distraction and
manages to strike his head armor the
resulting cut in the armor shockingly
reveals guan's face and he gets ready to
kill Wong I mean Kong but just as he is
about to proceed the little girl shows
up and distracts the Knight prompting
him to run towards her however this time
the night malfunctions for some reason
allowing Kong and tangerine to escape
back to reality Kong writes all of this
down while Guan approaches him from
behind he has visions of himself chasing
down Kong and tangerine in a fictional
World similar to what he just wrote in
his novel he proceeds to hurl rocks
towards Kong and one of them lands a
fatal blow knocking him out and sending
him into the trenches Guan approaches
Kong and prepares to land the final blow
whilst singing the lullaby he had made
for tangerine possibly trying to justify
his actions but right then Guan hears
someone say singing the lullaby and
immediately stops to follow the sound he
finds a little boy in the middle of the
road singing the lullaby then an
emotional Guan grabs the boy demanding
to know how he learned it the terrified
boy flees the scene and Guan chases
after him as he again has visions of him
in the fictional World chasing Kong and
tangerine from the view of the Crimson
night the boy manages to escape while
Guan ends up at a small party to his
shock he spots tangerines kidnapper
along with some of his friends and a
fight ensues Guan uses his powers to
defeat the enemies and interrogates the
kidnapper scared the latter finally
tells him the truth about his daughter
it is revealed that six years ago when
Tangerine was kidnapped she was
accidentally drugged with a dosage
higher than the minimum amount which
eventually led to her death so the
kidnapper put her in a sack and left her
on a mountain to rot overwhelmed with
pain and grief Guan tries to strangle
the Goon to death but link shows up in
the nick of time and stops him she then
knocks him out and Carries him to your
car when Guan wakes up he immediately
starts explaining what the kidnapper
said about Tangerine meanwhile Limu
talks to Ling via an earpiece and
instructs her to convince Guan that his
daughter is alive so she tells Guan that
the police are taking the kidnapper to
jail where he will be properly punished
however Guan begs her to let him have
the kidnapper after he kills Kong before
leaving to plan his next line of
approach shortly after Limu confronts
Ling and scolds her for feeling sorry
for Guan and not being able to fully
convince him he then confirms that the
kidnapper is right but in order to
manipulate Guan they have to use his
dead daughter as leverage in the
fictional World Kong and tangerine
escape the wrath of the night and come
to the city only to witness the horrible
things people are going through because
of the war the two make it to
tangerine's home and it turns out that
her parents had died a while back for
disobeying the curfew as they Converse
they are interrupted by a group of red
main followers who rummaged through
tangerine's home before laying their
eyes on the two intending to kill them
Kong immediately steps up to protect the
little girl from the attackers which his
live armor finds interesting in the real
world Kong meets with Guan on the
rooftop of a building unaware that he
was attacked by the same man earlier as
he explains his novel Guan finds out
that Kong has put him in his story as
the character of the Crimson Knight
hence matching the knight's head injury
with guanz when he was fighting the
kidnappers shocked Guan snatches the
notebook and goes through it only to
learn that the Visions he had been
having also matched the story Kong is
written what shocks him the most is that
his daughter Tangerine has been made a
character as well this means that Kong
has created a parallel universe through
his novels and that the content he
writes affects the real people on whom
the characters are based Kong explains
that the last chapter has himself and
tangerines surrounded by the angry mob
but he doesn't know how to defeat them
so Guan comes up with an idea that they
should win the fight the movie then Cuts
back to the parallel universe where Kong
is about to fight Redman's followers all
of a sudden the armor attached to Kong
exits his body and becomes an entity
that can conjure weapons on command the
armor plows through the angry mob while
Kong also joins in on the fight
afterward he learns that he has full
control over the armor because it has
way too much of his blood Kong then
stabs the armor in its chest to teach
him that he is in charge making the
object promise to never disobey him
again on Earth Guan calls Ling and tells
her that he has now decided to protect
Kong this is because he wants to save
his daughter in the novel The two men
then make it back to Kong's room where
it is revealed that his dad and Limu
were once business partners before the
former died in a tragic accident
surprisingly Ling is also eavesdropping
on their conversation she has now come
to the conclusion that Lee moo killed
Kong's dad and wants to cover up the
story by killing him as well enraged
Ling calls Limu demanding to know the
truth but he confesses nothing and hangs
up as a tiredling returns to her car she
is electrocuted by limu's henchmen and
placed in the back meanwhile Guan and
Kong head over to the library where the
latter continues to write his novel
while Guan prepares for any enemy forces
coming his way in the parallel universe
Kong and tangerine make it to redmayne's
Palace where they find thousands of
immobile Crimson Knights sitting on the
floor Kong then learns that the knights
only move during the day and that red
main had introduced the curfew law so
that the public couldn't find out about
this at the same time limu's goons
arrive at the library and Guan engages
in a fight with them he uses his powers
to defend himself but an attacker
splashes water on him and uses his
electrical prow ass forcing Guan to hide
in a corner a while later Guan thinks of
a plan and uses a rubber glove to kill
the attacker he confronts the Goon who
has superhuman strength but is hardly
able to overpower him fortunately Ling
wakes up and breaks free of the car
arriving just in time to prevent the
attacker from killing Guan the two then
work together and kill the last man in
the parallel universe tangerine and Kong
finally reach a room where they meet
Lord Redmayne who turns out to be a
massive forearmed Beast it's then
revealed that Kong is actually the son
of Redman's brother whom he had killed a
long time ago this matches directly with
reality as Kong's father was limu's best
friend and had died in an accident the
fictional Kong is furious after finding
out that Redman killed his father and so
he challenges him to a duel they go
outside where red main shows Kong the
tree in which his father was buried
underneath their fight begins and the
live armor separates from Kong's body
ready to give his best however the two
barely do any damage to the powerful red
Mane the latter manages to grab the
armor and crush it with his bare hands
turning it into dust just as red man is
about to kill a wounded Kong he is
distracted by a tangerine who plays the
lullaby on her flute she does so because
her father had taught her to sing the
song whenever she is in trouble and that
he will come to her Aid redmain however
grows frustrated with the tune and
captures Tangerine placing her inside
his belly back on Earth it appears as if
a third henchman is broken and stabbed
Kong without anyone knowing Guan and
Lang find him shortly after and take
down the Goon before rushing him to the
hospital later Guan stares at Kong's
laptop screen wondering what to do with
the novel he is shocked when Lee moose
suddenly enters the room and explains
that he had originally intended for Kong
and Guan to die together making it seem
like they had killed each other it was a
perfect plan because the police would
have read Kong's novel which has
tangerine's name on it making it seem
like he was the kidnapper while Guan was
a father who wanted revenge in the final
showdown between the two Limu demands
conch's computer but Guan refuses to
hand it over the latter then explains
that he can complete the story the movie
once again cuts to the parallel universe
where the Crimson Knight appears out of
nowhere with a machine gun in hand and
attacks red Mane intending to save his
daughter the gun finally does some
damage to the monster while Kong leaps
towards Redman and holds onto a sword
stuck to his forehead assuming that it
is his weakness Kong tries to pull the
sword out while the Crimson Knight grabs
it and drags it down Redman's body the
plan is successful and the giant monster
is finally killed as a result Tangerine
is freed from his stomach and the father
and daughter finally get to meet in this
universe in the meantime Ling finish is
reading what Guan had written while Lee
moo slowly Withers away as red main dies
in The Other Universe in the final scene
Juan hears the lullaby again and rushes
outside the hospital where he sees the
young boy from earlier only now he is
with a little girl none other than
Tangerine the movie ends as the Crimson
night hugs Tangerine ever so tightly
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching